Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P Yesterday on the bonus show,
we talked about the culinary scam that is the
boneless chicken wing. It's not a wing and a
lot of people called in. Here's one voicemail.
Speaker 5: Hey, Dave, you know, I was listening
to the explanation that you were on the terrible
false advertising with the boneless chicken wings.
You know, they're not real wings at all.
That's right. It would be like, you know,
somebody taking a liquid made from soy or
almonds or something like that and then
calling it something like milk, which is not
at all. You know, you just use that marketing
because it sounds better. You know, I was saying.
Speaker 1: Listen, we talked about this. You can
make a case that almond milk shouldn't be
labeled as milk because it's not milk. You
could make the case that a boneless wings
shouldn't be called a wing because it's
a chicken breast or a tenderloin. My view
on this is sort of if we agree that we can
name things based on their usage. Almond milk
and oat milk are used functionally as milks.
And that would be an argument for saying you
can call it milk. The counterpoint would be,
and this is the one that big dairy says it's
not milk and therefore you can't really call
it milk. I don't know what the answer is, but
it's getting very, very complicated. We have
a great bonus show for you today. Sign
up at Join Park MINKOFF. I'll see it up.